i was at the university of washington
for the past many years so pretty much
all of the work that i am going to be
talking about today are things that i
did
there and then yeah i'm starting at
northeastern next year so technically
i'm on vacation right now
but i'm going to be talking about a lot
of the work that i've been doing and how
that we can use video games for problem
solving because you know video games are
really good at actually engaging people
in solving problems like
taking people's attention and energy and
effort and focusing that on solving
problems but usually
the problems that they're solving in the
game are just a problem that was made up
for the game so that they could they can
have fun solving it um and so i'm kind
of interested in what we can do if we
can take uh the that that effort of
solving problems and
put it towards
solving problems in the real world
and the main
uh benefit i think from this is that we
can combine
uh human creativity and problem solving
and
spatial reasoning and those kinds of um
things that people have and are very
good at and combine that with the
computational power that we have to sort
of compute and crunch numbers and solve
problems and actually by combining both
humans and computers uh put that effort
towards solving problems that neither
humans nor computers would be able to
solve alone
and also through kind of the game
um environment actually train people up
to the point where they can make
contributions to be able to help solve
these problems and also give players new
opportunities to get involved in
areas of research that interest them in
kind of a citizen science kind of way
so the main question was how could we
use a game to solve a problem uh first
we would actually have to make a game
and find a problem that that we were
interested in solving
and so to answer that question a lot of
my work as a graduate student was
focused on
solving
problems related to proteins and protein
folding
with an and scientific discovery within
the domain of biochemistry and in
particular this was with a game called
foldit that i'll be describing for uh
i'll be discussing folded and some of
the results that we got for the the
initial part of the talk and then i'll
talk about some new games that we're
working on um towards the end but just
to give a little background on why
we made fold it and the problem that we
were trying to solve is i'm going to
talk a little bit about
proteins and protein folding and why we
thought that that might make a good game
to let players get involved in and help
out with
so proteins are these
biological molecules that are part of
living things they're sometimes called
the machines of the cell there's there's
sort of how things get done at the
molecular level um they include
doing things like protecting against
disease uh muscle movement digestion
manipulating dna and they perform a
wide array
of functions within the cell but the
most important thing to
remember about proteins is that their
structure determines their function so
if you want to understand how a protein
does what it does
you have to know what shape that protein
takes like what are the 3d positions of
of all the atoms
that make up the molecule
um
and so so yeah so if you want to
understand
the function of a protein and in some
sense how life works you want to
understand the shape and you want to
know the shape that that protein takes
so all proteins are made from smaller
molecules called amino acids that get
chained together
and every protein
essentially has a unique sequence of
amino acids that defines it uh that are
oftentimes represented as a string of
characters with one letter for each
amino acid and there are 20 to choose
from
and again each unique sequence of amino
acids will fold up into one unique
protein structure and this is sometimes
called its native structure um or the
because that's the structure that it
takes in nature this is also sort of the
the lowest energy structure that this
particular configuration of amino acids
can take
and so there are a lot of sequences
and there are a lot of structures
that exist
then there are a lot that we know the
structure of but they're actually
because it's a lot easier to determine
sequence information so it's a lot
easier to determine the amino acids that
make up a particular protein
and it's quite hard to actually
determine what shape that protein is
going to fold up into
there are a lot of proteins for which we
know the sequence of amino acids that
make up the protein but we don't know
the structure and so this is what's
oftentimes called the protein structure
prediction problem which is given a
sequence of amino acids can you
determine basically the 3d position of
all the atoms that make up that protein
in its native
folded structure
and so because of this the gap between
the number of known protein sequences
of amino acids and the number of known
protein structures is actually getting
wider and wider every year so they're
all these protein sequences that we know
but we don't know what structure they
fold up into and so we can't really
understand their function and how they
carry out their their function and their
effects
and so one approach that has been taken
to try to um
get around this and to try to help catch
up to the fact that there are all these
sequences that we know but we don't know
their structures is this distributed
computing approach so um
there have been these approaches where
you know when you're not running your
computer or you're not running your
playstation
you can donate that spare computation
time to helping to try to compute how
proteins will fold up and so two of
these projects are rosetta at home um
which is run out of udub primarily and
folding at home which is uh from
here right and i at one point this might
still be true but it was folding at home
was the most powerful distributed
computing cluster in the world
and all of that computational power
was being put towards basically
trying to figure out how proteins fold
and it's a really difficult problem
computationally because
even for relatively small proteins just
the number of possible configurations
that the protein can fold up into is is
you know astronomical right it's like
there's so many there are lots of
different degrees of freedom and uh you
know there's
there's just so many possibilities that
it's very hard to sort of search through
that space of possibilities or simulate
all of those degrees of freedom to see
how the protein is actually going to
fold up and on top of that sort of like
the energy landscape of these possible
protein structures is very very noisy
and so it's very hard to tell if you are
um
you know if you're in a local minima
that's good or if you're you're anywhere
near the right answer basically given
sort of what the the energy landscape
looks like nearby
but because it's all about the shapes of
the proteins and how they fit together
it's really kind of a spatial reasoning
problem about these 3d pieces and
so
we thought that um
because it's really kind of like a 3d
jigsaw puzzle or 3d tetris kind of in a
way is how we were thinking about it
we might be able to allow
people to get involved and to use their
spatial reasoning in a way to try to
complement
this purely computational search and be
able to actually
you know work together with the
computers to to
better search through the space and
better find
lower energy structures
and so to try this out we made uh foldit
which is
uh
an online game that people can play for
for free it was a collaboration between
the computer science department and the
biochemistry department at the
university of washington
and the players are
oh there's my mouse
the players are able to
compete and collaborate to try to find
well-folded protein structures the
players will start from some partially
folded protein structure
and
they have a whole bunch of different
tools in the game that they can use to
try to interactively refine and fold the
protein to try and find better and
better folds and so
then they also have access to
a lot of automated tools and algorithms
that they can run when they want so what
the player can do is do a high level
restructuring of the protein to try to
get the pieces in roughly the right
shape and then they can actually let the
computer take over at some point and run
some automatic optimizations to refine
the structure and so
and that way hopefully the the players
and the computer are actually able to do
each what they're good at the players
can kind of do high level spatial
reasoning and and pattern recognition
and they can let the computer take over
and do the low level optimization of the
fine details of the variables and the
degrees of freedom
at this point the game has been out for
over
over five years
and it's had over four hundred thousand
people play
so
next i'm going to talk a little bit
about the different pieces of the game
and how we took this scientific problem
of protein folding and
the proteins how do you solve the
problem of finding out whether it's a
local minimum or uh global i mean you
have the same issue right and
right so i guess in general the question
is sort of how do we know if the players
got the right answer in the end and
the the general answer to that is it
depends entirely on the
specific problem that we're looking at
and so i'll talk about that a little bit
in some of the specific
results um but
roughly speaking we can either
you know um
we can rely on sort of
data that
exists we can run experiments basically
to see if they if they've gotten the
right answer or we can use data from
existing experiments um in the case one
example that i won't talk about but i
guess probably will make it a little bit
more clear is um
there are some cases
using x-ray crystallography where you
get sort of enough experimental data to
confirm
that you know if you have the right
structure it'll sort of fit with the
data but you don't actually have enough
data to get the structure if that makes
sense so once you sometimes people in
that case people oftentimes use um
similar related structures
to to confirm
the structural the the x-ray
crystallography data but in some cases
when there aren't enough similar
structures or any similar structures
then you know you can use sort of
computational methods to try to come up
with something that's close enough that
it fits the experimental data that you
can say that you got the right answer oh
okay so i'm going to talk a little bit
about a couple of the different
components that went into to making the
game and that we that we worked out to
actually
allow the players to contribute to
solving
these scientific problems
so one of the first things was the
interactions and we wanted this is sort
of like the tools that we gave to the
player to allow them to
actually manipulate the protein and
refine the structure and what kinds of
tools they would have to to sort of
search the space and we wanted to make
sure that the tools that we gave them
were actually you know scientifically
accurate and realistic and they would
actually result in plausible protein
structures and so because of that
the
interaction that the players can do are
all sort of based on
um
optimizations and routines that exist in
the rosetta software package which is
actually developed at the
it's the same software package that's
used by rosetta at home the screen saver
and so when you actually interact with
the protein in the game essentially
what's happening is your sort of user
interface manipulations get packaged up
and turned into
optimizations that get run underneath by
the state of the art protein modeling
package and then the results are given
back to you
in real time and so we actually spent a
fair amount of time testing this
initially to see what kind of interface
players would like and and doing user
testing and so originally some of our
interfaces were kind of more indirect
with like levers and sliders and things
like that where you could um you know
you would sort of indirectly manipulate
the protein but actually through um
through sort of testing those different
interfaces with users we found that a
more direct kind of interaction was
desirable where you actually sort of
like click on the protein and pull on it
and um and launch menus and that kind of
thing from the protein itself to have
kind of a more direct manipulation kind
of interface that the the players and
the users enjoyed more and found more
intuitive
so we really tried to we tried to to get
to the point where you felt like you
were actually touching and moving the
protein directly yourself
while still maintaining the
the um
the the sort of the scientific
underpinnings of the rosetta engine
so we also designed a number of
different visualizations for the protein
to indicate where things were
sort of either working or not working to
draw the player's attention to where
they might actually want to focus
their work and we indicated a lot of
these with sort of little widgets that
are um
that appear around the protein in
particular areas where things are wrong
or right and these included things like
clashes that show up where
there are two pieces of the protein that
are too close together
and so you actually want to pull those
apart
there were voids where there are empty
spaces inside the protein that you
actually should try to fill in and
compress the protein
it also
exposed hydrophobics
which are
essentially pieces of the protein that
are on the outside sort of exposed to
the the water that the protein is in but
would actually prefer to be on the
interior of the protein and i'll talk a
little bit more about those later
and hydrogen bonds which are good and
kind of hold the protein together
and so all these are indicated by these
kind of widgets that appear around the
protein
in terms of the goal one of the
challenges was
again we don't we don't actually know
what the right answer is in the problems
that we're interested in the players
solving and so we have to direct the
players to an unknown solution
and so unfolded the player's goal is to
get a high score and their score is
uh
basically the energy of their current
protein fold which we can get again from
the the rosetta biochemistry software
but because the low energy is good we
actually take the energy and we invert
it and we negate it and then we scale it
up by a large number so instead of
trying to get you know a low a small low
negative number you're actually trying
to get a really a high positive number
which seems more like what people are
used to trying to get in a game and so
what this means is that higher scores
for the player are
lower energy structures and hopefully
more likely to be close to the native
structure
but it's not just the individual players
working
by themselves there's actually a lot of
social elements in the game including
um
a leaderboard for individuals so while
you're working on the game you can see
in real time your score updating as you
change your protein but you can also see
the scores of everyone else who's
working on that particular structure
and how well you are ranking against
them so
for anyone who's
not in first place they basically have a
sort of a goal to try to get a higher
and higher score and if you're in first
place you probably want to get a few
more points so that whoever is in second
place can't catch up with you um and so
what this means is that we never really
had to
set a
you know a score threshold like in our
we didn't have to try to come up with
the score that we wanted the players to
get to it's basically set dynamically by
the players who are competing to get the
highest possible score
in addition to
the individual leaderboards we actually
allow the players to form groups
and
when they are working in a when you're
in a group with other players you can
actually trade your structure with them
so when you're working on something if
you get stuck you can actually send it
out to your group and they can pick up
where you left off and continue working
there and the group's score is
essentially the the highest score of any
individual person in that group
and so in this way there's sort of
there's competition and collaboration
for
uh the people who are working and
playing in the game and on top of this
they're sort of more long-term leader
boards where you can accumulate lots of
points over multiple puzzles so there
and there's different categories of
puzzles so players can uh get a lot of
sort of positive feedback and rewards
for doing well in the game
so another uh key aspect of the game was
actually training new players who come
into the game
protein folding is it's a relatively
complicated and it's a relatively
complicated game so we have to actually
teach players a fair amount before they
can actually get to the point where they
can compete with other players online
and so to do this we actually have a set
of
tutorial introductory levels that
introduce the concepts that are
necessary to to play the game and these
are actually like offline puzzles where
we know the answer they're all kind of
handcrafted and they have they do have
particular goal scores
and they're you know they're not
competitive there's no leaderboard but
they have um
these hints
that show up
and
sort of guide the player
from
for what they need to do to actually
complete that level and there's a whole
series of these introductory levels that
start out very simple with small
proteins with just a little bit wrong
with them and they get more and more
complicated to the point where hopefully
if you've completed them you're able to
actually compete with the other players
online and once you've fixed everything
then you know you get
fireworks and special sounds and things
like that and you can proceed on to the
the next level
and
after the game had been out for a little
while we actually asked some of the
players who are who are doing well the
top players basically what their
background was in biochemistry to kind
of see
if the
um tutorials were actually helping if it
was just you know we didn't know if it
was just people who are biochemists who
are playing the game or what so we
actually ran a small survey where we
just asked some of the top players who
are what their background was in
relation to to biochemistry and it
turned out that actually about
three-quarters of them didn't have
anything more than one undergraduate
course related to biochemistry
so it seemed like this would indicate
that you know the the
there was enough of an introduction to
take people who didn't really have a lot
of background in biochemistry and
actually let them play and compete in
the game and and stay around for a while
and potentially beat some of the
biochemists who are playing the game
so
once we had the problem mapped onto a
game
um we didn't necessarily expect that we
had gotten it right the very first time
that we tried it so we had the game um
up and running and at this point we were
actually able to get a lot of data from
the players who were playing both in
terms of sort of like the scientific
structures that they were coming up with
and gameplay data about you know what
kinds of um how long they were playing
what kinds of tools they like to use and
so on and so he undertook
this process of continuous refinement
and experimentation basically to make
the game a better and better
problem-solving tool for the players
which is this process actually still
going on today
since at the very beginning the
community was still sort of learning how
to play and we were still sort of
refining the game but essentially
what we do is
roughly speaking on a weekly basis
we'll we meet with the biochemists who
are collaborating with and we'll talk to
them about the open problems that
they're interested in what they're
working on
and we take those and we turn those into
what we call puzzles and those get
posted online and
while those are available online they
can get sent out to all the players who
are playing the game
and they can you know go through the
process of trying to fold the protein as
best as they can seeing how well the
other players are doing and competing in
the leaderboards
and all the time that they're playing
we're collecting back solution data from
them the structures that they're finding
how they're searching through the space
and that all gets logged and recorded
and then you know at the end of the week
or however long the puzzle is up for we
can then take that information aggregate
information about the solutions that the
players came up with and present that
back to the scientists who can then try
to do some analysis and see um you know
how well the players were doing if
there's something yeah
how do you decide how long the problem
should be a particular puzzle should
have
is it like just randomly decided or is
it based on
how difficult
your perceived
difficulty is or do you have a target
score which you take the puzzle down
after they reach yeah that's a good
question um they're usually up for like
a fixed amount like when we post them we
say this puzzle is up for this amount of
time
and
um sometimes we'll adjust it but usually
it's you know there's a starting date
and a closing date and and for the most
part those are usually about a week long
it's not that's more
we we've actually arrived at that mostly
because that
puts um
like a weekend
at least in the uh the the duration and
so that lets like everybody play um
there's a lot of there's sort of like a
a lot of people sort of around the world
who are playing and so we try to to time
things so that
you know everybody who wants to play
kind of has a chance to compete it's not
totally clear that that is
the
actually the best amount of time for
getting problem for solving a particular
problem but it's sort of more to support
the community um there might it might be
better to leave them up for longer um
but but we don't we don't actually know
for sure about that
right and so then we can sort we can
take that aggregate data and that
analysis from
the um the solutions that we got back
from the players and essentially feed
that back into the next round of puzzles
so you know if there's something that
the players were doing that seems like
it wasn't beneficial then we can maybe
penalize that in the next round of
puzzles or if there's something that
they were doing that was good we can
actually try to give more of a bonus for
that or you know if there was a bug we
can fix the bug and and and work through
things that way
and so it's sort of through this cycle
of continuous refinement that we're able
to continually improve the system and
the kinds of results that we get from
the players
in addition to posting puzzles we're
also often posting game updates kind of
like expansions
where we have you know new features new
levels new tools
support for new kinds of scientific data
or visualizations in the game and so on
and
we're also getting back a lot of
gameplay data from the players in terms
of oh yeah
are you altering the physics somewhat
yeah i guess you could say that yeah
there's a lot of
it's familiar with
yeah there's there's you know there's a
lot of kind of like knobs for scoring
and the different tools and that kind of
thing um what sort of like what the
parameters of the the particular puzzle
even like where we start the players out
from you know sometimes um sometimes
we'll run a puzzle
and
we'll take
the good solutions that players found
and actually use those as a starting
point for the next round so that kind of
everybody can start from there sometimes
you know in like a
a design related puzzle maybe there will
be
you know too many um
of a particular amino acid and then
we'll penalize that the next time around
so that there aren't as many um so it's
kind of or
you know there'll be a new
um
you know a new visualization that we
want to support that we think will help
then and then we can this is sort of
conceptual feedback in a way right okay
but you're not changing
the sort of
physical interactions that are in or are
you
well we can sometimes we'll change like
the energy the energy function right so
you know if you're if the atoms are this
far apart like how much is that worth
sometimes we'll adjust that a little bit
okay yeah so even even at that level
okay but will that then go into the main
just standard rosetta engine those
things or is it very problem specific
that's in these cases it's generally
problem specific we can we can there's a
lot of things that we can adjust on like
a per puzzle basis including for example
like the exact
you know weights of terms and energy
function and that kind of thing usually
actually more more often it comes the
other way like um
the even the
the sort of what what you might consider
like the standard or canonical energy
function that's sort of recommended for
use in rosetta can change it does change
over time and so you know when that
changes
we change ours as well to match it
yeah
so sort of in some sense yeah like the
physics the underlying physics of the
game are being because it's just it's
not
100 accurate and so it's always being
refined over time
so for one example of something uh one
experiment that we ran actually to
compare um
different versions of the game to
improve it over time was actually uh how
we
introduced the
the um
the the information in the tutorial
levels of the game so there's these
tutorial levels right there meant to
teach the players particular things and
how are we going to convey that
information to them so we ran um one of
the experiments experiences we ran
actually compared different methods for
comparing or for
conveying that information to the
players um and these are sort of these
little hints in the in the video before
these are these little like hint bubbles
and so we actually compared three
different ways
one was just giving them no help at all
one was giving them what we called
context insensitive help where it just
sort of gave them an instruction manual
at the beginning of the level with
everything that they needed to know and
next and previous
page buttons and sort of a picture
of what was relevant to that particular
piece of text
and
the third one was what we called context
sensitive help where there would there
were these event triggers that would
sort of try to figure out where the
player was and what they were doing in
the level and actually pop up a little
piece of text that indicated what they
needed to do next
and for each of these we compared
how far players made it through
the introductory levels on average
and i believe these are our median
levels completed and so for no help
unsurprisingly was the worst and players
only competed completed about on average
of four levels giving them the context
insensitive help was a little bit better
but actually not that much better than
not giving them any help at all um and
the context sensitive help
was actually by far the best and they
completed about seven levels on average
and so for example this is why that
context sensitive help is now the
actually the the help system that's left
in the game because that was the most
successful
uh but it was kind of interesting that
you know in play testing we had sort of
noticed that if you just give if we just
gave people kind of like a block of text
at the beginning of a level they would
usually dismiss it and not read it and
then maybe later realize that they
wanted to know what was in the text but
um it usually wasn't wasn't that helpful
and so it was kind of interesting to see
that
giving the user everything they need to
know in one text block right at the
beginning was actually
not that much better than giving them no
help at all
so that's sort of an overview a
description of the system and how we uh
how we've been working on it and how
we've been refining it over time so i'm
going to talk a little bit now about
some of the results that we've gotten
from the players from their game play
in a couple different areas the first is
a protein structure prediction and so
that's
basically you know given a sequence of
amino acids trying to find the lowest
energy structure for that
that specific protein
also in the development of algorithms
that can refine protein structures and
actually maybe feeding back some of the
strategies that the players have
developed into automated methods and a
third is actually protein design and
trying to
come up with novel synthetic proteins
that don't exist in nature that might
have new and useful functions
so
for protein structure prediction we're
looking at
can players basically figure out what
structure a protein will take given its
sequence of amino acids and so to do
this
uh one of the things that we did was we
ran a comparison between
the folded players
and
the
sort of state-of-the-art protein
structure prediction algorithm at the
time which was called rebuild and
refined and we took
um
structures
that
exist that we we had and
these were
structures that
had been solved
by experimentalists but had not yet
actually been published and so that way
we knew that the players weren't
cheating by looking up the answer which
i think sometimes they do if we run a
published structure
and
so
what yeah so we took these 10 structures
and
essentially we let the folder players
work on them and we let the rebuild and
refine algorithm sort of run until they
had converged and what we compared was
the
the carbon alpha rmsd which is roughly
speaking a measure of the distance
between proteins and we we looked at the
the rmsd for each um
for the players and the algorithm with
respect to the correct native structure
once that had been released
so at that point we knew what the right
answer was
and
what we found was that
in
five of these ten cases the players did
better and about three of the cases they
did kind of similar and in two cases
they did worse
and
what we were interested in was what was
it that the players had done
that
the the algorithms weren't able to do
basically
and so one so as an example of that
um we can take a closer look at one of
these particular structures and see how
what the players did compared to what
the algorithm did
and this plot is kind of an rmsd plot
where the x-axis again is rmsd and it's
distance from native so um zero would
basically mean right on the right answer
and the y-axis is energy and lower is
better energy so kind of the bottom the
bottom left there is kind of like the
best area to be
and so
each dot in the graph in the chart
represents a solution structure produced
either by
the players which are green or the
automated algorithm which is yellow
and what had to be done actually in this
particular structure was what we called
a strand swap because
um
you can see this is where they this is
the starting structure that they were
all given and here
this blue region
which is kind of the tail of the protein
is actually
very hydrophobic and exposed on the
exterior of the protein and because it's
hydrophobic it actually would prefer to
be on the interior
and so this is
um what one of the players did this
trajectory they took is this green line
here and you can see that they actually
got
they had to
essentially get a really bad energy and
a really bad score
before they were able to
get the this blue hydrophobic region of
the protein buried correctly on the
interior so they they almost had to
unravel the protein entirely and so what
they were able to do was kind of escape
this energy minima and find
the right answer
where
you can actually see this little kind of
island of green
dots here
is is structures with swap strands and
only the players were able to find that
the the automated algorithm actually
kind of got stuck you can see there's a
little a little notch in the energy
landscape
kind of right around
right around here
where
the automated algorithm kind of hit and
didn't really go much further
and so what we found there interestingly
was that the players and were able to
actually correctly um fix they were able
to fix incorrectly folded proteins
that
had and outperform purely computational
methods in particular they were very
good at
making these kinds of restructuring
operations where you had incorrectly
exposed hydrophobic regions and actually
um
moving the uh
the structure out of these local minima
that were caused by these incorrectly
exposed hydrophobic regions by sort of
making the structure worse to make a
space for those hydrophobic areas to get
buried on the interior of the protein
which would generally cause the
automated methods to kind of get stuck
and give up and not escape that local
minimum
um
okay so
we had seen that the players were
actually able to do um some oh yeah
one um i mean you can't predict how much
time we actually spent but how long did
the algorithms actually take to uh do
the following stuff yeah i don't i don't
remember exactly how it was it wasn't
like we didn't run them for for a week
but i think it was it was sort of a
standard algorithm and i think we sort
of ran it until it had converged and
kind of stopped running if we could i
said it was a it was like a randomized
algorithm so
you know
if we had just continued it running
indefinitely
possibly you know it would have
eventually come up with that but but it
sort of converged to this particular
region of the energy landscape and so so
those are multiple ones converging to
different regions is that how you got
the
multiple dots for the algorithmic
solutions
um
it was i believe that that particular
algorithm would kind of use
um
it could use a lot of
um structures at once kind of like
evolve a population of structures over
time by trying different random things
on them
yeah
okay so we had seen that the players
were able to in some cases actually do
quite well in folding protein structures
and so we were curious what kinds of
strategies and
kind of heuristics they had developed
and we wanted to see if we could
actually take those and apply those back
into automated methods
so
what we added to the game was what we
called the cookbook
which
is essentially a
a tool to allow the players to code up
their strategies here
is is this video is showing one of the
interfaces for it where there's sort of
a block based
sequence language where
you can you can basically just make um a
linear sequence of commands
that correspond to you know moves in the
game
we actually more recently
added a
lua interpreter is embedded in the game
so the players can just basically write
lua scripts with you know all the
control structures and variables that
they want
um
so in addition so in addition to just
writing and running these uh recipes in
the cookbook we call them the players
are actually able to share them online
with other players and take other
players recipes and run them or edit
them and then re-share them customize
them and so on so there's actually a
whole you know you can see there's these
some share buttons down here so there's
actually a whole sort of portal section
of the website that's dedicated to the
recipes that the players have written
and run
and so we were interested in if the
players were actually using this this
sharing um
interface and aspect of the game and it
turned out they actually were and
they were
uh sharing in
some sort of interesting patterns so
there were some there were some recipes
where um
a player would make a recipe public and
shared and a lot of other players would
download those and make their own copies
and their own modifications so these
sort of shallow but wide kind of trees
of um sharing oh in fact as i should
mention so in this each each node each
circle basically represents a different
recipe and the size is is roughly um
is related to how popular it was how
often it was run
so you can see there were these in some
cases these really popular publicly
shared recipes that had a lot of
descendants where players would take
that recipe and make their own
local modifications maybe share some of
them with their groups
there were some interesting cases where
there would be a really popular public
recipe and the player who wrote it would
kind of iterate on it and make multiple
changes and then share with their group
and then keep working on it and then
eventually sharing a new version of it
like a version 2.0 with everyone and
and make that public
and then there are other kinds of ones
where you know some of the children
would become actually much more popular
within groups than the original parent
was so it's interesting to see that um
players were actually taking advantage
of this recipe system and modifying each
other's shared recipes and running each
other's shared recipes
and so we were also curious about what
what the
the algorithms that the players were
sharing and coming up with were and so
when we looked at the very top recipes
in terms of how often they were run we
noticed that there was this one recipe
that was like really really popular in
terms of how many times it was run and
like three times more popular than the
next previous one and so we were curious
about what this particular recipe
contained
and this was actually a really short lua
script that was called bluefuse version
1.1 that one of the players wrote and
essentially what it did was it adjusted
the inter the the forces that the atoms
used to push each other apart the
inter-atomic repulsive forces and
interleaved that with discrete and
continuous optimization
which sort of allowed the protein to
kind of contract and relax and let the
atoms get a little bit closer to each
other than normally they would be able
to by adjusting their repulsive force
and when we looked at that
one of the biochemistry we were working
with that looks
very familiar um
we've been working on an algorithm that
does almost the same thing
that we haven't published yet which they
called fast relax and it did a very
similar thing by adjusting the the
inter-atomic repulsive force and doing
sort of optimizations in between
and so we were curious how these two
algorithms
compared to each other and so we ran
them on a benchmark set of proteins to
see
how well they did
and in these particular charts
time is on the x-axis and energy is on
the y-axis so the longer an algorithm
was run for
the more
energy it could sort of ring out of the
protein so again the bottom left here is
kind of the good region to be in
and kind of as a baseline we compared to
classic relax was which was at that time
the the published
algorithm the scientists were using
and when we looked at the fast relax
algorithm of course it did quite a bit
better than the the classic relax
and we looked at the player's blue fuse
algorithm
it landed somewhere in between it wasn't
quite as
efficient
as fast relax but it was actually still
a little bit better than the classic
relaxed which was interesting yeah i'm
trying to interpret the y-axis here is
this a good increase i mean like yeah
from 150 to 170 i like
without knowing anything about the what
that means it doesn't seem like a big
difference
it's it's a pretty it's i mean this so
um
what these out these relax algorithms do
is they don't really make like a major
changes to the structure they kind of um
they're sort of things that you would
kind of run near the end to refine a
structure that's already mostly in the
right place uh if that makes sense so it
just sort of helps all the pieces of the
protein kind of
kind of get into a little bit better
position so um for that it's i think
it's a pretty good
changes
no no yeah yeah
yeah these are sort of more like in end
game refinement kinds of things
um
so
let's see
um right so the
the so it kind of appeared that the
the scientists developed
faster lacks was doing a little bit
better than the player developed one but
to compare a little bit further we
actually re-implemented
fast relax in
the lua scripting interface because the
players didn't have access to all of the
sort of parameters and options that the
biochemist did when they implemented
faster locks so we we implemented fast
relax using foldit's lua interface as
closely as we could and when we re-ran
the the benchmark what we actually found
was
the player the bluefuse algorithm was
actually a little bit more efficient
than the faster lacks algorithm it was
able to get
a few more points a little bit quicker
and
this was actually the sort of domain of
time that the players were running blue
fuse for
when we looked at how often how
long they ran it for on average so it's
very interesting to see
that for the use case of the players um
they actually and the interface that
they were given to develop
an algorithm they actually came up with
something a little bit more efficient
than what the scientists had developed
for their use case
so when we were looking at algorithm
development we saw that the players were
actually able to sort of independently
discover an algorithmic technique
through this end user development
approach that was actually more
efficient than some of the previous
published algorithms the scientists were
using and there was this whole social
collaborative
development and identification of
algorithms online
so yeah so the next the next part i'll
talk about in terms of folded results is
protein design and this is actually
coming up with
a new sequence of amino acids basically
that will fold up into a protein that
has a particular structure so in some
sense it's it's kind of
the
the inverse of structure prediction
right you want to you want to design a
new synthetic protein that will carry
out some particular function
and so
we added a lot of new tools for protein
design basically allowing the players to
change um the amino acids that actually
make up a given protein in the game
and so there were new tools new tutorial
levels to introduce these and so on
and
we
one of the the cases that we looked at
was to develop an enzyme
for the
the catalysis of this reaction called
the diels-alder reaction um
where
essentially there's this protein here
that you know looks like the rest of the
protein and in the middle there's this
small molecule that we want to catalyze
the reaction for
basically by redesigning this brightly
colored region of the protein to have
more contacts with the small molecule in
the middle and that's what we asked the
players to do
and this was actually a really
interesting case because we were able to
take the designs that the players came
up with in the game and the biochemists
were able to actually test these out in
the wet lab and see
actually how they worked and if they if
they the players had improved on the
initial structures at all and then
whenever we did that we're actually able
to take the most promising structures
that came out of the wet lab experiments
and feed those back into the next
round of puzzles and so it was this very
iterative process but this time we're
actually integrating actual experiments
in the wet lab with the sort of
iterative process of the game and the
refinement
and so again this is kind of a slightly
different view but
we ask the players to redesign that kind
of loop region on the top right to have
more contacts with the the cyan small
molecule there
and
what we ended up with which was sort of
a player and scientist co-design enzyme
was this dark blue one where they added
two helixes and they were able to make a
lot more contacts with the small
molecule and it was in fact a
13 amino acid insertion from the
starting structure which is quite a
drastic departure in terms of
redesigning a protein and the the new
enzyme actually had about 17 times
improved efficiency over the starting
enzyme so not only did they make a
really drastic departure from the
original structure but it was actually a
lot more
active a lot more efficient than the
original enzyme and in fact the
biochemistry we were working with said
that it was such a drastic change to the
structure that they might not actually
have considered it themselves but the
players were actually able to to come up
with something that worked
so in terms of protein design we're able
to see that they were the players were
actually able to improve an existing
enzyme uh
a really exciting part was actually this
scientist and player collaboration where
they would actually test out the things
that the players had come up with in the
lab and feed those back into the the the
game
and the players were actually able to
make these interesting and surprising
changes to structures
so those are some of the results
some of the things that we're looking at
now in the future for foldit is
interfaces using connect and leap and
other kinds of like tablets and
multi-touch interfaces to see if those
can help to improve
the things that players are able to do
fitting us
predictive structures to electron
density this is sort of a piece of
experimental information that we can get
that might help players be more accurate
in their predictions and a variety of
different kinds of designs we're looking
at um in particular like designing drugs
and small molecules rather than proteins
so i have a
i have a little bit of time left i guess
so i'll try i'll try to go through these
like really real relatively quickly so
there's time for questions but i wanted
to mention two
new games that actually we're working on
now
one of them is called nanocrafter and
this is based around synthetic biology
and the second one we're probably we're
thinking about calling paradox and this
is about software verification
so
nanocrafter this has worked with several
other
researchers but the idea with
nanocrafter is it's a game about
synthetic biology we're curious to see
what kinds of nano devices we can
actually engineer
based on using
small strands of dna to self-assemble
into
nano devices and nano structures that
are governed by dna-based pairing
mechanics
so you know a and t and c and g want to
pair with each other and so if you
program sequences of dna just right then
you can sort of predict and model how
they're going to um how they're going to
bond to each other and actually make
them build you know scaffolds and
structures and things like that another
important mechanic here is strand
displacement where if you have two
strands of dna that are already bound
together and you have some other strand
that comes in and actually
binds to one of those better it'll
actually sort of kick off
the one of the strands that's already
bound
and
you'll end up with sort of a new a new
um
system a new setup and i have some
videos that will hopefully make this a
little bit more clear and again one of
the cool things here is we can test
these in the lab
so in the game for example you might
have a something
that looks like this but it really
represents a
a strand of dna that looks like that in
the top left so a lot of the sort of
details of exactly what the base pairs
are are abstracted away
and you kind of get these like lego-ish
building blocks that you can use
so maybe i'll just show one of the
videos these are some of the tutorial
levels where
essentially in all the tutorial levels
your goal is to
free these strands
that are have a little star on them and
so
what's going to happen is
the player sort of restructures some of
the pieces of dna and then hits play and
then sort the dna dynamics kick in and
there's a strand displacement and they
freed the star and so they win that
level and then there are sort of these
puzzles that get a little bit more
complicated these are the tutorial
levels
and so again that's that is sort of the
strand displacement mechanic that lets
you make interesting cascading kind of
moving devices
and then you know they get the levels
getting more complicated um
as an example
this is this is a walker that we built
to test out the system but
you can make sort of robotic devices on
things that move around so you can sort
of see there's these two legs and
they'll actually take steps and this is
a really short track but you can make it
longer and the little things of dna will
will walk along the
track i don't know if that's totally
clear but
um
the legs it comes with the legs
sort of this
let's see this region here is the walker
and then these things they're kind of
like grass they kind of come up and
those are the parts of the track and
then there's little bits of fuel that
come in and they sort of remove the
walker leg from a previous part of the
track and it moves forward to the next
part of the track
so this is something that we made just
to sort of get the idea if it could
support a larger system
these are some solutions that players
have submitted to some of the challenges
that we've posted
this is
this is an interesting one that just
forms into a
structural three-way junction here
automatically so it kind of like builds
a little sub-component of what might be
a larger structure
this uses
a bunch of similar copies of the same
um
the same sort of strands to actually
make a sort of a polymer
that's self-similar to itself it just
sort of like assembles into a long a
long string
and this one is interesting it might
actually be more of a
exploitation of the physics system in
the game than anything else
but
it's kind of it just kind of swims along
using like a little i don't know motor
or tail there
again that that might just be more yeah
an exploitation of the physics in the
game um
so yeah so this is just actually
released relatively recently last year
and so that's kind of interesting to
think about um how this has this sort of
dichotomy between the tutorial levels
and the science levels for the players
and um one of the the tensions that we
always have is um you know how soon
should you take the players out of the
tutorials into the science puzzles so
they can start making a contribution
versus you know how you have to sort of
teach them everything in the tutorial
levels as well so how could we guide the
players through those
given the skills that they've learned
things like how can we actually teach
the players the rules of the game we
have we've tried a lot of things like
videos slideshows text again
one of the interesting things is how can
we let players share and customize sort
of sub components that they've built out
of pieces of dna so that you don't have
to like rebuild everything from scratch
or see everything on the screen at the
whole time
and i sort of skimmed over this but the
challenges that we give to the players
here are actually very open-ended
textual challenges and so we actually
ask the players to rate each other's
solutions and it would be interesting to
try to figure out how we could
incentivize and train players to
recognize and rate good solutions
in this yeah um
there's kind of two independent
physics running at the same time there's
the the rules
uh
and in a general sense there's the
the domain
bonding rules basically like these two
or these two pieces of dna react in this
and this order right and then um there's
sort of the layout you know where things
appear on this because that just says
there are these different
you know pieces of dna somewhere there's
no sort of geometric spatial information
right yeah it's not at the level of base
pair it's sort of at the level of
collections of base pairs which we call
domains but but basically yeah it's like
these two
the next the next thing that happens is
these two react kind of clicking forward
into the upper left-hand screen so
suggest me there's some hydrodynamic
model yeah so then there's sort of the
layout that makes everything gives
everything a piece a place to appear on
the screen and this is
um that's actually just box 2d
running yeah so we use it sort of like a
mass and spring
body and spring kind of um lay out okay
yeah so as i say i think they're sort of
they
this is sort of exploiting that aspect
of the
physics
layout simulation to make something that
kind of moves across
um
do i have time say like five more
minutes
okay so i'll go through this really
really quickly as well um this is
another game that's based on software
verification um
it's currently called flow jam but we're
sort of revamping it quite heavily and
we're probably going to call it paradox
this is also with some other
researchers at uw
but the basic idea is that we want to be
able to prove a particular piece of
software is free from certain classes of
bugs or errors
and the approach that we're looking at
is to do this through type annotations
and in java
so the assumption is that most programs
probably will not type check just right
away and so adding all these annotations
could actually be quite costly if you
have sort of um
an experienced or expert programmer do
it
so what we wanted to do is have a game
where the players are essentially trying
to infer the best set of type
annotations
with the fewest type checking errors
that could then go back to an expert
programmer and they'd have less work to
do than if they had to start from
scratch
so roughly speaking the type annotation
in java is just some extra type
information you can apply to
a type if you wanted to say for example
prove that a a program did not have any
null point or d references you could
have a type system that encoded whether
a reference was null or not null and
then for example if you try to
dereference the null uh something that
is potentially null you'd get an error
right
and so right so actually having uh you
know highly skilled inexpensive labor do
this could be expensive
so
so it might be so in this case what
we're trying to do is translate the the
code into a set of constraints that then
players can solve in an abstract sense
try to minimize the number of
constraints that are violated and then
turn that back into type annotations on
the code and the original programmer has
much less work to do to verify that
everything
works correctly
and so right now the way the gameplay
works is
i'll just again show the video
it's basically a constraint graph with
variables and constraints that are
connected to each other with edges and
the player can
the primary mechanic for the player is
to select
variables to be optimized by painting
over them and once they select some
uh by painting those variables that they
selected are handed off to an automatic
solver
that then optimizes them underneath and
returns the result to the player so
again the the the player is essentially
sort of scheduling and and um piecewise
optimizing a large optimization problem
and the hope is that the player can do
um some form of visual
uh decomposition and scheduling to do
um come up with a
better solution faster than just
throwing a purely automated method at
the whole problem at once sorry i don't
understand what's going on i agree i
paint and what is it doing
so each of the
the um the nodes
is either the the blue the blue nodes
are variables
and the green nodes are the constraints
and those are given from the original
code yeah these are derived from code
and so the constraints are generally
things like you know um you know x is a
subtype of y
or x is the same type as y
and so
then
when the player
paints
oh i guess this oops
this might also be obvious but this is
all sort of like placeholder art right
now um
when the player paints they're
oops
they are basically selecting variables
and when they finish painting
the system sort of packages up the
variables and the related constraints
into uh an optimization problem and
sends that off to an optimizer that runs
in the
background um it's optimizing to satisfy
the maximum number of constraints
it's actually it's a it's max sat
underneath so there the variables are
boolean variables and the constraints
are clauses
and so this does not direct the map onto
the code this is a far more abstract one
yeah yes it's much more abstract than
the code yeah
yeah
um
right does that does that answer
a bit a bit
we
but the basic idea is you have a big
at this yeah at this point once it gets
to the game it's more or less
uh it's very far removed from the
original code and the structure of the
original code um to some extent but the
basic idea is that um
you have a big optimization problem and
we want the player rather than just
trying to purely automatically solve it
all at once we want to let the players
sort of subdivide and decide how long to
spend on each region
of the problem
so this leads to some interesting
questions such as how can those graphs
we're seeing were actually quite small
compared to like the real problems that
we want to solve so there's some
visualization issues in dealing with
solving visualizing large constraint
graphs actually there's a lot of
different levels that we need to
organize and present to the player you
know one code base can generate a very
large number of levels that need to be
solved
and
potentially i think it would be
interesting to actually learn strategies
and heuristics from the players and feed
those back into automated methods kind
of like we did with the cookbook and
fold it
and this actually we're actually looking
at putting this game on mechanical turk
as well
and actually paying people to solve them
so it would kind of be interesting to
see what uh impact if any sort of the
free
gamified version has versus the you know
non-gamified paid version um and how
that affects you know how much people
solve how how long they'll play for
okay
so
um
right so in conclusion i think that um
you know foldit has shown a lot of
promise for combining humans and
computers and solving these difficult
computational problems uh we're looking
at some other things in synthetic
biology software verification and so on
and so i think there's a lot of
interesting things to be done and
questions to be answered
there and
if you'd like to try any of them uh
here's the the urls you can play the old
the old version uh the current version
flow jam um as well and there's my email
and website if you're interested so
thank you thanks for your attention i
guess i went a little bit longer
um
if someone is not a programmer uh how
likely is it that they could actually
get anything i mean just looking at a
constraint graph if you if you're not a
programmer how likely is it that you'd
actually make any progress in solving
that
um well i think because it's
it's
totally removed from the code i don't
my guess is that it wouldn't matter
necessarily if you know how to program
at all
but i mean
for the folded example you had names
which said
stuff like this is hydrophilic and this
should be inside
you can't even give them heaps here
right i mean i mean how would they well
i mean we we sort of can't i guess we
have civil or at least this one we have
some similar um sort of like context
sensitive hints that show up but they
don't have anything to do with
the code right it's more like the
constraint craft but it's kind of yeah i
mean i guess this is more removed from
the application domain right so
we can't any you know there's any hints
that we give the players aren't
going to
um
tie back to the original code or
anything in any way right it's kind of
it's kind and kind of a way right like
if you play fold it you know you can
learn
you know theoretically about the
biochemistry right and if you learn some
biochemistry then that can actually help
you in the game presumably but in this
case it's because it's completely
removed from
the
the the code and sort of like the source
material right um it's like it's a com i
think it would be a completely different
set of skills right that you would
develop to solve these kinds of problems
than you would if you were coding
yeah if that answer hopefully that
answers the question yeah
yeah um do any biochemistry classes use
all of it to
help students learn about protein
folding
yeah yeah that is that's definitely the
case um we
i mean there are teachers i mean some we
occasionally get emails from like
teachers in colleges high schools who
say they're using it um
we we also have been developing a
version that could be used in
um
used in classes right so you can load in
more more um structures that might be
more relevant to like a curriculum like
glucose lactose
you know hemoglobin that kind of thing
so it's definitely been used you know
i've got people have assigned
puzzles as homework
right it was actually used in the
um edx's i think their first
their mooc that they did for for
biochemistry one of the assignments was
um to play a certain amount of the the
tutorial levels basically so we actually
had made like a special version for them
um as well and the
um
the the nano crafter also one of the one
of our collaborators has actually used
that sort of in his class to teach a
little bit of synthetic biology i think
because when you can see the strand
displacement happening and things moving
i think it's a little bit easier to to
understand than you know just sort of
reading about it with static images
so i think that yeah both both of those
i think could be useful for education
and have been to to different extents
already used in the classroom um
yeah
so what's that
so like interesting
contributions you obviously have that uh
cookbook mechanism and but like you're
also gathering a bunch of vlogs as well
from players um are those at all like
useful for like kind of conferring like
strategies like would at all possible to
be possible like
something that simulates a folded player
yeah that's an interesting question and
so
originally before before we even did the
cookbook we were kind of thinking that
maybe that's what we would do we try to
like
you know
see what
players do and learn
at the level of individual actions
what the players do but
um
instead we sort of figured well
why don't we see if they could actually
they probably know very well what they
want to do so why don't we see if they
can actually code them up themselves but
an interesting thing now is
i think a lot of the advanced players
they use a lot of scripts and
all the scripts are very it seems like
they're very context sensitive like for
example i was talking about the blue
fuse it it only works like in this
context of you're near the end you have
a relatively well refined structure and
you just wanted everything to sort of
fit into place a little bit better and
so i actually think an interesting thing
to do at this point would be to to do
something similar like try to figure out
if you could
um
you know given a protein structure which
script is the best script to run
basically by looking you know like
features of of structures and which
scripts people ran at that point and
then
yeah right like simulate a folded player
at the level of what script do i run
next rather than you know
what
sort of atomic game element do i run
yeah
people to play the um
can i talk about how we got people to
play the game
um
yeah i mean we tried what we tried to do
was there were a lot of things we tried
we did um i mean this you know this
whole iterative process you know early
on we
we um
we had a lot of like sort of like rapid
as rapid as we could do sort of
prototyping um early on i mean we do
this with a lot of the games like you
know we try to get something up and
running as quickly as possible have
people play them you know do play
testing see what people figure out what
they don't figure out um
we
you know we we throw away a lot of sort
of like the early designs that don't
really work that well until we come up
with something that you know seems to um
be enjoyable as well as actually address
the the scientific problem at hand
um
we tried to put in a lot of
um rewards right at different schedules
so there's everything from like while
you're playing the game if you make a
good move there's like a little pop-up
right that says like good job um
to you know you can do
um
well at a particular puzzle
which you know
and then there's these like meta leader
boards right that you know actually can
take a couple months maybe to get to the
top of right so there's sort of like
these there's there's positive feedback
and rewards from you know the the half
second to the like four month mark
basically um to sort of how to try to
get players involved
um there's a we tried to put a lot of
like social things into the game and the
website right so there's groups so that
players work together i think i think my
feeling is that the groups are actually
quite important for this sort of like
people wanting to stick around and play
more
rather than feeling like they're sort of
just working on their own they're
actually working with other people
um
and
in addition to that we also we also put
a lot into
um giving them feedback about the
purpose of the game and like what's
going on behind the scenes and the
science right like why are we posting
this puzzle you know how does it relate
to like something in the real world how
is what you're doing helping um
you know asking them like what features
do you like what things would you like
to see what things aren't working you
know so sort of trying to engage the
community
um
yeah so
and then you know
also trying to get
um
doing out like outreach right going out
and giving talks talking to to the media
we go to like public science events and
that kind of thing so just trying to
like get the word out as much as we can
that the game exists and
that kind of thing